[Music]
on this Monday night Israel's deadly new
strikes the killing of an Iranian
commander in Syria the mounting Carnage
at refugee camps in Gaza and the
backlash against Israel's prime
minister as Bethlehem marks a grim
Christmas where is Alexi naly finally
answers about the vocal critic of
Russia's president mourning a Canadian
luxury men's where Mogul he was a risk
taker what Harry Rosen focused on to
soar to success and taking it back
navigating the retailing rules of gift
returns global national with G of
freezen reporting tonight meu
Gara good evening and Merry Christmas
Israel's war on Hamas is not letting up
during the holidays and the violence is
spilling over into other parts of the
Middle East according to Iranian State
media an Israeli air strike outside
Syria's Capital has killed an Iranian
military commander Iran vows Israel
quote will certainly pay for the attack
Israel is not commenting on those
reports back in the occupied West Bank
Bethlehem a city that's usually bustling
at Christmas is somber today grief has
replaced Festive Celebrations as more
blood is shed in Gaza McKenzie gray has
our top story
tonight as the sun rose on Bethlehem the
star that Christians believe guided the
three wise men to a newborn baby is
still lit but the rest of the biblical
city is closed for Christmas no tree no
lights only a scaled down Mass inside
the West
Bank replacing the traditional nativity
scene a baby Jesus in a destroyed
building representing those killed in
the
conflict
and that scene is playing out just 80
kmet away inside Gaza daylight shows one
of the deadliest Israeli air strikes yet
Doctors Without Borders saying 131
people are dead and over 200 injured
after two refugee camps in Gaza were
targeted the Israeli Prime Minister
visiting troops on the front lines amid
international calls for a ceasefire but
Benjamin Netanyahu reiterating fighting
will continue we're facing monsters
monsters who murdered children in front
of their parents and parents in front of
their
children but it's Israeli parents
continuing to put pressure on nety to
get Hamas to release the 120 hostages
they're holding heckling the Prime
Minister during a speech in the knesset
many more hostages are still had held in
Gaza and we want people to remember them
and to not forget that they're there and
they need to come home back in Bethlehem
a different pain felt by Palestinian
Christians who've watched an estimated
20,000 people die in Gaza according to
the Hamas run Health Ministry we didn't
even decorate anything because of the
war and innocent people are dying and I
feel so bad for them there'll be nothing
under the tree this year for 9-year-old
Sophia tabah but that doesn't bother her
children in Gaza they don't get G gifts
or anything because of the war Sophia's
family will still have a Christmas
dinner as they think about the 1.9
million people who've been displaced in
Gaza many of whom Wonder every day where
they'll find their next meal McKenzie
Greg Global
News Russia's invasion of Ukraine is
also dragging on with Russia claiming to
have captured the small Eastern
Ukrainian city of marenka these images
from May reveal how the war has
pulverized what is now a ghost town
Russian President Vladimir Putin says
his troops can now move into Marena to
help defend nearby Don
which Russia occupies Ukraine for its
part denies it has lost control of
marenka the team behind one of Putin's
most vocal critics Alexi navali confirms
he is alive and
well we find Alexi after three weeks of
uh search the incarcerated opposition
leader has been moved to a Siberian
penal colony considered one of Russia's
toughest prisons navali met with his
lawyer at the remote facility today
concerns were raised about the
47-year-old's well-being after he failed
to appear in court earlier this month
and his team couldn't contact him naali
is serving 19 years on charges of
extremism a Quebec Superior Court has
approved a class action lawsuit against
day schools on behalf of indigenous
people the suit alleges rampant abuse
and a subpar level of education at the
institutions attended by thousands of
children attendance overseen by the
Quebec government and its school boards
on behalf of Ottawa was enforced by
either provincial or federal authorities
the lawsuit includes all First Nations
people who were required to attend
between 1951 and 2014 and all inuy
between 1963 and
1978 it is a somber Christmas for the
family of a famed Canadian retailer
Harry Rosen whose name is synonymous
with fine men's wear has died sha O'Shea
looks back on how rosen's dream
flourished into a retailing
Empire it's a retail brand that stood
the test of time Harry Rosen as a
retailer uh is an iconic retailer uh
probably one of the best men's wear
retailers in the entire world and it's
Canadian this is the company's flagship
store in Toronto one of 17 across
British Columbia Alberta Manitoba
Ontario and Quebec back in 1954 Harry
Rosen opened his first store with his
brother using a $500 down payment to
rent the space he was a risk taker he
was a dreamer he was an
entrepreneur and it was a time that
allowed somebody like that to dream and
to um do something different Rosen was
handson someone focused on the consumer
Harry Rosen I think found a formula of
of good customer service uh Brands and
products his motto treating customers as
individuals that's the real business
we're in he knew his customer and he
knew his Customer because he studied his
customer he spent time with his customer
it was all about customer service
everybody loves to talk about customer
service Harry Rosen did customer service
but it wasn't all success Harry rosen's
expansion plans to the United States
didn't work out so he pulled back and at
one point he tried selling women's
clothes that wasn't his thing and um he
didn't do as well in that but when it
came to luxury men's wear there was
nothing like it his son Larry took over
the day-to-day business decades ago and
now there's a third generation of Rosen
running the business but Harry Rosen
stayed involved as the original face of
the brand and it is quite sad that you
know Harry himself the founder has
passed away leaving a Canadian retailing
Legacy Harry Rosen died on Christmas Eve
he was 92 years old Shan OA Global News
Toronto got a gift that kind of missed
the mark this holiday season coming up
what you should know before making a
[Music]
return if Christmas is the season of
giving then the season of gift returning
is about to begin let's face it not
every present is a keeper Sean preville
explains what you should do before you
head to the store and why making a
return could cost
you as people come together to enjoy the
holidays with family and friends there
may also be an exchange of gifts in fact
can Ians are expected to spend almost
$900 on gifts this year according to a
retail Council of Canada survey but when
the holidays come to an end some
purchases may head right back to the
store retail adviser David inre of dig
360 says Shoppers should research return
policies to know how much time you have
or if you can return it at all I think
the more careful we are in our research
on the product we're going to buy in the
first place be it for ourselves or
someone else probably the better it's
going to be for everyone involved for
some stores there may be no returns for
a certain period of time such as during
boxing week and depending on the
business you may also face a restocking
fee especially if bought online retail
analyst Bruce Winder says it's in part
due to online shopping's popularity and
the higher rate of returns that
retailers see most retailers now are
looking for ways to try to um I guess uh
re re-engineer the processes and sort of
the risk involved and the cost involved
when it comes to what you can and can't
return it's best to check with the
retailers but there are some items that
can typically not be returned at all
including underwear intimate items
skincare products if the seal is broken
and often final sale items it's why
Robert damala of return bear says if
you're stuck with an item consider
passing them along instead of putting
them in the trash we always encourage
like recycling of those materials or
sharing passing along of those items to
uh to to friends colleagues or those uh
you know who might benefit from them or
need them as opposed to just throwing
stuff in the garbage so as people share
the joy of the holidays with each other
wer says whether you're giving the gift
or receiving one no what to expect I
think the key message here is buyer
beware um and receiver beware Sean
preville Global
News some journalists have paid the
ultimate price for reporting on Israel's
war on Hamas after the break Donna will
be here to speak with a Psychiatry
Professor about those who put themselves
in danger seeking the truth and the
moral courage which he says they all
[Music]
have in the news business you just get
on with the job and sometimes that puts
you in the line of fire whether it's
online harassment being targeted by
hostile governments or Worse dying to
get the story Al jazer cameraman Samar
Abu Daka was killed in Gaza his
colleague bureau chief W aladu was
injured they were covering the aftermath
of nightly Israeli air strikes D is also
buried his wife son daughter and
Grandson according to the committee to
protect journalists no other War has
taken so many journalists lives in such
a short time span it says at least 69
journalists and media workers mostly
Palestinian have been killed since the
Israel Hamas conflict began on October
7th and then there are the reporters in
other places who have been killed
threatened beaten and imprisoned for
carrying out their work while Wall
Street Journal reporter Evan gershkovich
spent his 32nd birthday in a Russian
prison he was detained in March and
accused of Espionage and in China which
reporters Without Borders calls the
biggest Jailer of journalists more than
100 journalists are detained so why do
they do it well it takes moral courage
that's the title of Dr Anthony
Feinstein's latest book he was the first
to study trauma in journalists who cover
conflict he's a neuros psychiatrist and
professor at the University of Toronto
and he's with me now Dr Feinstein thanks
for being with us why did you write this
book what why dig into this question
about why some journalists pursue
stories at such great risk to
themselves I think that's the reason um
what drives people to take such you know
extra ordinary risk to bring the news
and while I think that motivation is
very complex there's a central theme
that links all the journalists who I
interviewed across 19 different
countries and I believe that's something
called moral courage well how do you
define moral courage for first of all so
for moral courage to take place you have
to have a Confluence of certain
variables it needs to be principles got
to have by principles then you need the
drive and the endurance to sustain those
principles and then it has to take place
against the backdrop of danger so when
you've got good
principles the drive and endurance to up
uphold them and danger in the background
and those three things coales at the
center of it all you've got moral
courage and it's there I believe to try
and keep at Bay very difficult
unpleasant set of emotions that come
with something called moral injury well
I want to get to moral injury in a
moment but do you think people are born
with moral courage or is it something
they developed through their career you
know I think some people have a very
finely set moral compers early on in
their lives one of the individuals in my
book G liser who was instrumental in
helping the country of Namibia get
independence as as a as a young kid 13
years of age you see evidence of her of
a very strong moral compass and moral in
Integrity other people they learning
from the parents parents can be very
powerful Role Models you see it in some
of the journalists that I that I
interviewed and then it also comes from
an innate character um things you can
learn from school as well so I think
there going to be multiple things that
coales to give give give people moral
courage and the people that I interview
have a moral courage in abundance you
know they're at the far end of the moral
courage spectrum because they are taking
on really difficult regimes um they they
can pay a very high price for their
moral courage and they do now I know
that Palestinian journalists in Gaza are
in a different category because they're
not only putting themselves in gra grave
danger of course they can't leave and
they're covering what's happening to
their own people often their own family
members and yet people like Al jazer W
Dadu who has lost his own family members
they they carry on as a psychiatrist how
do you explain that drive you know all
my original work was done on Western
journalists who fly into a conflict and
leave after four to 6 weeks or so then I
did a study of Mexican journalists who
don't leave a little bit like the
journalists in you know in Gaza in
Israel and um they get trapped in very
violent societies and they still have
this desire to push on and tell the
story um there are some journalists who
back away from that but many keep doing
it um and it is an extraordinary bravery
because it comes to such a high price as
you highlight not just for them but for
their family members and loved ones and
just kind of reinforces how very
dangerous journalism can be in a
troubled World it used to be that
labeling your Flack jacket or your
vehicle with press would sort of Shield
you I know I did that back when I was a
foreign correspondent you'd sort of be
left alone to observe that's certainly
not the case anymore what do you think
we lose from the world when journalists
are
silenced so I'm so glad you asked that
question because the countries that are
that are focused on places like Russia
belus aaban Bangladesh Etc you know
journalists are often the last vestages
of civil Society these authoritarian
dictatorial rulers have Stripped Away um
all vestages of democracy the the courts
are in their pocket the judges are are
are coward um they've run the NOS out
the country um but there are few lone
journalists who stand up to them they
represent the remnants of Civil Society
in these countries and so they fulfill
such an important role and the citizens
of these countries who are oppressed by
these dictatorial leaders know it they
look to these few journalists as a
beacon of light as a beacon of hope that
perhaps down the road they're going to
be better days because if you don't have
some kind of independent journalism then
Civil Society I believe is lost Dr
Feinstein thank you for your work thank
you for um focusing on trauma and
journalists it's much appreciated thank
you for your
interest thanks Donna speaking of
journalists it takes a small village of
them here at Global to put on this
newscast and other current affairs
programs next we'll honor them and the
crew who keeps everything running
smoothly in our annual will
[Music]
salute time now for a Christmas Day
tradition here at at Global News when we
honor everyone behind global national
the West block the new reality and our
Network news coverage our Mighty and
dedicated Team Works 247 to keep you
informed about what's happening around
the world I'm Nara on behalf of Donna
far and everyone here at global news
thank you for your support over this
past year have a safe and happy
Christmas I'll see you back here
tomorrow have a wonderful
[Music]
night
[Applause]
[Music]
n
you
[Music]
he
[Applause]
[Music]
he
excuse
[Music]
me coming Sirens ring out over Ukraine's
Capital as Russia unleashes a wave of
air strikes decided to stay with the man
who led an increasingly totalitarian
government for 20 years reip tiia ferdan
has been declared winner of the runoff
election redond Shannon looks at how he
did it and what it could be for turkey's
[Music]
[Applause]
future
[Music]